sí buenos días las sesiones empezarán
hoy a las 8 de la mañana hora de
washington y se tratarán dos temas
específicos
el primero es cómo activar la innovación
climática en este punto se conversará
sobre la influencia de la tecnología
para lograr la neutralidad de carbono y
también pues cuáles son las
oportunidades para construir una nueva
industria del futuro el segundo tema que
se tratará será las oportunidades
económicas en la acción climática aquí
se piensa hacer un énfasis en cómo
generar empleo en esta acción climática
algunos de los participantes a resaltar
en este segundo día será por ejemplo el
primer ministro israelí benjamín
netanyahu el presidente de españa pedro
sánchez y estará también michael
bloomberg ex candidato presidencial
multimillonario ex alcalde nueva york
que ahora asume el rol de enviado
especial en la acción climática para el
gobierno de estados unidos también
estará bill gates que pues es fundador
de microsoft ya lo sabemos y también que
escribió recientemente el libro como
evitar un desastre climático finalmente
start up in which se avanzará en la
agenda de la plan de infraestructura de
eeuu que incluye varias acciones contra
el cambio climático